pete buddha judge former mayor of south
bend
his father actually one of the most
prominent radical theorists
in the academy he was the a founder and
a former president of the international
ramsey society referring to antonio
gramsci this
brilliant marxist philosopher and
communist politician
one of the people really credited with
creating political correctness who might
detail in my
book buddha judge is now the
transportation secretary
and buddha judge says you know we need
to
really rethink the way we do roads i'm
not just here to fill potholes baby
racism is built into our roads and we've
got to fix it
we're going to create billions and
billions of dollars in economic
opportunity and we have to make sure
that happens equitably so let me talk
about two parts of that
the first is where the investments
happen where are we going to fix the
bridge where are we going to improve the
road where are we going to lay the pipe
and we got to make sure we're doing that
equitably especially knowing that it was
often in black and brown communities
that there was either a failure to
invest and you didn't have a good road
or transit system in a certain
neighborhood
or the investment came through in the
wrong way
like a highway dividing a black
neighborhood in two there's been a lot
of that
in the american and the interstate
system the interstate system was built
to keep
certain groups in and certain groups out
so it was built on a racist system
correct
yeah often this wasn't just a an act of
neglect often
this was a conscious choice there is
racism physically built into some of our
highways
those damn roads i hate those racist
white supremacist roads
got to cancel those roads we got to kick
those roads off twitter you know
we got us those ah man it's it's one
thing
for according to democrats half the
country to be
nazis and white supremacists racists you
know
but the roads too we gotta lose all
right gotta we gotta remake the whole
country then
what is buddha judge saying why is he
saying it
he's saying that the highway system
he's obviously exaggerating
immensely but i want to get i want to
give a good argument for for the point
he's trying to make
he's saying that america is totally
racist
right the whole the whole country is
racist it's been racist forever until
like right now when we're still racist
but we're in a crisis and the future is
not going to be racist but racism racism
racism
and so we got to fix that and you know
the roads being a part of america are
part of this american racism and they
were used they were built by racists
for racists and everything is about race
and therefore we need to do something
about it now
i'm going to grant i'm not going to
grant his point that the rhodes are
racist or something
but i am going to grant his broader
observation about human nature take race
out of it race just like science is the
only way that we can now think about the
world
race is the only way that we can think
about sin
so if you if you use the correct
language here it starts to make more
sense he's saying look
human nature is broken people are sinful
and the people who built the roads are
sinful and
there was sinfulness built into this
and therefore it's not perfect and
therefore there's some injustice
involved
and that's why we need to correct that
injustice
okay that's a that's a sort of
unobjectionable point right
of course all human endeavors are
involved some sin because our free will
has been compromised by sin because
adam had to eat that damn apple right
really evade it first but it's adam you
know okay i don't want to get into the
gender politics of it okay we're
sticking with race for now
the problem here is buddha judge seems
to
exclude himself from the sinfulness of
man
from this brokenness the left broadly
when they say everything was racist in
the past but now we're going to redo
everything and make it better
they seem to ex and you know they're
using this term race as a stand-in for
sin
they're excluding themselves they think
they're so perfect
so the reason they're going after the
roads is because the roads
just connect the whole country they're
right at the heart of the country it's
how we move it's how we live
so if you can remake even the roads you
can remake the whole country it's it's
about how ambitious this revolution is
going to
be and the reason that their
revolutionary radical plans are destined
to fail is because they themselves
are just as sinful as the people that
they castigate
and furthermore because they don't even
recognize that they're talking about sin
they think it's all just about race or
something
because of this secular religion of
progressivism
they can only see skin deep they can
only see the physical stuff they can't
really make sense
of the metaphysical stuff which is
really what it what is the motivation
here
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
you